and i i honestly was excited to have you
here so i could learn about this stuff
you know uh
metaverse i hear this term all the time
metaverse and i literally and i'm a
boomer maybe but i'm imagining ready
player one you see the oculus and all
this kind of stuff
is there a place in the metaverse that
is ready for that are we going to be
living in these internet sleeves i think
we will live in the metaverse at some
point i think if you ask me the number
one place where a lot of money is going
to be lost it's in it's in land in the
metaverse because i don't think we're
there yet nfts we were there because
nfts are using the foundation of social
media to be real back to fashion
i knew that if i was right
a year and a half ago that if this was
gonna pop off people were gonna put it
into their social that's exactly what's
happened
the problem with the metaverse is we
have nowhere to put it
and we're not living in there yet so
there was a lot of apps that came out
too early when the iphone came out lag
about our real estate within the
metaverse because there's no place to
show people that we have
it's all the same [ __ ]
yeah the world's the same how do i flex
how do i flex and flex is the cynical
point of view
i actually think a lot of people
sho like shop creatively like there's
people that want to buy valencia like
all the brands all over themselves and
they just i want they're basically
saying [ __ ] you i'm rich yes right or
what they're really saying
i'm so insecure i got to show you how
rich i am yeah please like me [ __ ] me
yes [ __ ] me that's exactly right please
please that's right comma please the
but what a lot of people do
is actually express themselves through
it right so it's like like the converse
there is a decision you guys knew
balancing it is a decision all black is
the decision facial hair is it's all a
decision we don't think about it but it
is
and i think
humans need to communicate yeah through
words right through the written word
through songs through art
what we buy is actually the biggest way
we communicate in the world because it
shows up every day
what zip code do you live in what car do
you drive and most of all what clothes
and stuff do you have
someone influences those decisions
many things people we look up to
who what tribe we want to be in yeah
right like let's talk about something i
think all of us can connect on remember
when
hip-hop
started to wear vans
that was an evolution yeah i was like
what
you know and lil wayne was like a real
part of that skateboard crossover but
like i this is what i do for a living i
walk the streets digitally i'm like wait
a minute
southside atlanta is wearing surfer boy
sneakers yeah yeah yeah what's this mean
this is some crazy fusion [ __ ] this is
an evolution i looked at it as a
positive i'm like good more let's all
get like let's all come together like
keep mixing so
but
consciously
when that became appropriate because
this you know because pharrell did this
or asap crew did that or
wayne did this there's some kid
in an urban area who did doesn't feel
associated or maybe can't afford
jordans
that's like yo i can go and buy a pair
of vans yeah and for 40 bucks be in this
little community
so there's a lot of things that go into
this a lot
yeah
acceptance tribalism communication this
is all human [ __ ] yeah that was a real
ignorant question i had about the meta
versus why are you paying so much for
land when you could literally live and
build anything you want to it's all
virtual reality right i could have the
biggest palace on earth i don't have to
pay contractors to build something
well well it depends on how that
platform works you're talking about
something pretty interesting i think the
vulnerability to the metaverse land
thing is we're not there yet and by the
time we are there yet five seven nine
years from now
it's gonna be owned by the person that
owns the hardware yeah
it's gonna be this that owns it and by
the way
if you're mad at mark zuckerberg now get
ready to be real mad yeah because meta
and oculus is so much further ahead of
everybody there's not even a close
second not an amazon not a [ __ ] china
not anything there's nothing close
[ __ ] oculus is so far ahead
and you know it'll be really interesting
because they've got andrew bosworth
who's got it back to the jock right he
he was a beast at facebook they now made
him in charge of that whole thing
i think they got a real shot really if
we're gonna get to ready player one if i
had to bet i think it's gonna be meta
that gets most of the people to be into
the metaverse and then whatever land
they're gonna sell is gonna be the land
because the the great thing about real
estate in the real world is the earth is
the earth yeah
yeah
yeah yeah the bad thing with land in the
metaverse is i can roll out vaynerland
right now and start selling plots and
you can and they can and so it's
unlimited inventory which is bad for
supply and demand it's unlimited
inventory and it's also it doesn't take
you time to get somewhere like it takes
you time to go from new york to saint
bart's in the metaverse i imagine you
just snap your fingers and then that's
why
but that's why the metaverse is going to
win
yeah yeah but long term but i guess
because all we pick is convenience there
are people right now always have
on delivery fee for their coffee in the
morning because that's how valuable
convenience is
you're paying four dollars to [ __ ]
seamless
four dollars on top of your coffee yeah
for it delivered
and you're like crying about not having
enough money yeah
that's how powerful convenience is that
you were financially anxious every day
of your life yet
three times a week because we're all at
home
you don't want to get out of your house
to go downstairs in a big city to get
your coffee you'd rather pay four
dollars yeah
in service fee
and people talking [ __ ] like [ __ ] my
boss no [ __ ] you don't buy nine dollar
cups of coffee yeah yeah i'm with you
now here a question about buying in the
metaverse then why do you need land in
the metaverse if i could just to your
point immediately transport back to my
place be out in the metaverse i don't
need to live in the country because your
place your place in real life no i'm
saying if uh let's say how about
vaynerland let's say vanderland is
selling pro plots but meta versus where
all the same reason you go to anything
in life
because other people are there that you
want to be with yeah i'll go chill with
them and the brand exclusivities in one
world versus the other if nike only
signs with meta and i want to be wearing
that in the metaverse i'm going to be in
that every restaurant tour every night
club business every fashion brand should
know how to navigate the metaverse very
simple it's always the same dynamics
it's human truths the reason you're
gonna put a [ __ ] helmet on
is because everyone else did when
everybody was holding onto their
blackberry i was like you're gonna give
up your blackberry all my [ __ ]
corporate friends right now i gotta
touch the [ __ ] buttons i'm like
you're going to and the reason i was pot
committed to that was i knew that
everybody would have an iphone and it
would systematically eventually break
you down guys that clip is brought to
you by blue chew the makers of hard
dicks and happy wives that's right your
girl deserves it even your side chick
deserves your best and the way you're
gonna deliver it to her is getting on
that chew same active ingredients it's
inside cialis or viagra but this is the
chew this is the one we rock with and
this is the one that we do spinal damage
to the ones we love with
make sure
you get your first month free by going
to bluechew.com
and use the promo code andrew you just
gotta pay five dollars shipping that's
it thank you so much for watching the
clips keep supporting the podcast we'll
see you soon
you